foreign
[Applause]
hello how's everybody happy Friday
everybody glad it's Friday thank you for
being with us wow
what a great crowd we're back in New
York there are a few conservatives a few
normal people in New York City they're
all in this room that's it anyway thank
you for being with us busy news night
this Friday and uh not for by the way
for Joe Biden he's back in Delaware for
another weekend of rest and relaxation
we have full coverage of his latest
cognitive malfunction it was pretty bad
that's coming up tonight also England's
own Piers Morgan will weigh in on Megan
and Harry
all right the royal couple will
quarterly
they are struggling to cope with a
cartoon that made fun of them these are
people that say they want privacy but
they show up on Oprah on Netflix they
write books they don't want privacy they
want money they're just lying to us
anyway First We Begin tonight with
something really deadly serious and
America is now suffering from what is a
severe violence and murder crisis now in
fact Country-Wide murder rate is now at
the highest point more than 20 years and
it's going higher it seems every day
with another 4.3 percent increase in
2021 alone now of course you won't see
any of these statistics on other
networks because they hide for example
in 2020 we had 574 riots and they
refused to call riots riots we had
thousands of injured cops billions in
property damage and of course we had
dozens of dead Americans but they
weren't rights according to the left you
won't hear about it from Democrats
they'd love to politicize so called gun
violence only when it's politically
convenient will they talk about it now
that's because these murders are
devastating and by the way often
happening in Democratic run cities and
towns because of democratic policies and
a democratic narrative defunding
dismantling the police vilifying the
police zero bail laws releasing violent
felons from prison lacks prosecution and
now predictably every night city streets
all around the country are lined with
bodies so the question is how many more
lives are Democrats willing to sacrifice
for a narrative that is false how long
will they cling to defund dismantle and
no bail laws for example recently in New
York City the D.A dropped murder charges
against the guy accused of stabbing a
person to death over stolen shrimp and
then immediately released this guy from
prison and now he's only being charged
with first degree assault now meanwhile
out in Los Angeles it's not much better
the D.A out there suspended a prosecutor
for misgendering a child molester
charged with murder who claims to now be
a trans woman why should that be a
factor if you commit murder you should
be charged with murder now she
purportedly beat a man to death in the
woods but according to the media mob the
real threat to America well that would
be Florida Governor Ron DeSantis because
he allowed his state to execute a
violent criminal who murdered two people
in fact many in the media mob
enthusiastically promoted the murderer's
final statement quote I know I hurt
people when I was young I really messed
up but I know Rhonda santis has done a
lot worse I doubt he killed people now
keep in mind Florida's crime rate has
dropped to a 50-year low with murder
down 14 percent and of course no state
is immune from any crime but take a look
at your screen look at Flagler County
Florida a six foot six 270 pound high
school student look at this viciously
beating a teacher's assistant striking
her 15 times knocking her unconscious
and in Orange County a violent gang
member named Keith Moses he is accused
of murdering three people according to
reports quote Moses armed with a Glock
40 allegedly fatally shot a woman found
around 11 A.M returned to the scene
hours later and opened fire on a TV
reporter and a photojournalist before
entering a home and shooting yet another
woman and her nine-year-old daughter but
when Moses was arrested he whined and he
cried and he accused the police of being
too rough take a look
again for everybody
they're not killing him they're
arresting him which is what their job is
now the guy's accused of murdering a
nine-year-old little girl and a local
reporter and another woman at least in
Florida if he's convicted he will never
see the light of day outside of prison
ever again that's what every state needs
to adopt everybody seems to agree
now meanwhile in Texas this newly
released video is going viral this shows
a Good Samaritan somebody risking his
own life chasing down a drunk driver who
attempted to run from the scene of a
crash that killed a Texas police officer
look at this heroism
[Music]
somebody
you'll kill somebody
stay right there
you stay right there mother
I don't want to mess with that guy
anyway but he did the right thing now
clearly Law and Order is something that
Americans value and for good reason
because without safety life becomes very
difficult when you have woke DA's
refusing to prosecute even violent
criminals and recommending lenient
sentences in the name of quote social
justice they are hurting their own
community so what can be done well out
in Missouri the Attorney General is now
working to fire a St Louis circuit
attorney named kin Kim Gardner now keep
in mind St Louis is one of the most
dangerous cities on Earth and in return
Gardner is now playing the race card
take a look at this
wow it is true my office could have done
more
to say we did nothing is only
disingenuous but it's willfully ignorant
of the reality of our court system
we're going to fight very hard for
justice in spite of the vitriol the hate
the racist attacks the known
manipulation of the court procedures to
make sure our office fails hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else